[Musique]
parmi l'éventail de personnes qui
adhèrent aux théories du complot les
profils sont très variés on retrouve de
tout une mosaïque hétéroclite de
conviction de valeur de croyance et
d'idéologie mais dans ce grand ensemble
on a vu un type de mouvance prendre de
plus en plus de place dans les réseaux
sociaux dès les premiers instants de la
pandémie il s'agit de la conspiration
alité
dramatique de retour décrypteurs le
temps de cette émission ça fait plaisir
de te revoir merci bon conte
spiritualité ce concept là est en vogue
en ce moment mais ça va tu dis un
certain temps des jeunes en fait le
terme a été inventé en 2011 par deux
chercheurs qui s'intéressait à ce
phénomène là donc finalement aux gens
qui s'intéressent à la fois à des
théories du complot donc des
conspirationnistes mais aussi à des gens
qui s'intéressent à la spiritualité et
là dedans on englobe beaucoup de choses
donc c'est un peu hétéroclite ya la fois
des gens qui s'intéressent à leur
bien-être physique et spirituelle des
gens qui s'intéressent aux médecines
douces au yoga à l'alimentation vegan
parfois qui va en voir des croyances
ésotériques et donc c'est pas un groupe
homogène il faut pas généraliser non
plus ce n'est pas la majorité des gens
qui s'intéressent à ces choses là qui
sont conspirationnistes mais ce qu'on
voit depuis quelques années c'est que
beaucoup d'influenceurs et de groupes
sur les réseaux sociaux de gens qui
s'intéressent à la spiritualité en
général et bien de plus en plus se
laisse attirer se laisse influencer par
les théories du complot et de cette
union la a jailli un autre terme pastel
qu anne donc pastel parce que souvent
sur ces compte instagram on parle de
yoga de nourriture bio c'est des belles
couleurs pastel et le certains d'entre
eux commencé à faire la promotion de la
théorie conspirationniste crâne et os
je suppose au leader
ats
heureusement le pnd avec bayal et
maintenant bouchra comment ces journées
de transition de la croissance
personnelle du yoga du bien-être en
général aux théories conspirationnistes
devant le lier ce fait les chercheurs
qui ont inventé le mot con spiritualité
notait que au départ c'est démontre
qu'on peut considérer comme vraiment
opposé les théories conspirationnistes
c'est souvent ça tire souvent des hommes
tandis que le mouvement du bien-être la
croissance personnelle ça attire plus
souvent des femmes et ça se concentre
plutôt sur le soi même et non sur la
politique mais on peut trouver des
points en commun entre ces deux univers
là par exemple les gens qui
s'intéressent aux médecines douces
souvent vont remettre en question ce que
disent les autorités ont remettre en
question la médecine occidentale ils
vont des fois avoir des croyances un peu
alternative un peu ésotérique et donc
c'est un peu si on veut dans leur adn
d'être méfiants envers ce que disent les
autorités et donc c'est un point de
départ pour adhérer à certaines théories
du complot si aussi des gens parfois qui
se méfie beaucoup des compagnies
pharmaceutiques et donc c'est ce sont
des gens qui étaient déjà prêts et
disposés à s'opposer aux vaccins et
finalement notons aussi que les gens
considèrent que chacun est responsable
de son bien-être par son mode de vie par
son alimentation est donc que c'est pas
au gouvernement de prendre soin du
bien-être la population et à partir de
là il ya certaines personnes qui se sont
laissé influencer par des théories même
encore plus extrême le vaccin servirait
à dépeupler la planète ou encore à
implanter des puces 5g et on sait que
lorsqu'une personne croit de la
désinformation ça la rend plus
susceptibles de croire à d'autres formes
de désinformation dans d'autres domaines
mais quand même quand on adhère ac yoann
c'est un autre pas qu'ont franchi
comment on se rend jusque là encore une
fois dans cette dynamique de conspirer
dualité oui mais ça peut surprendre a
priori parce que qu annoncé ça attire
beaucoup l'extrême droite américaine et
les gens qui s'intéressent à la
croissance personnelle bien-être
habituellement c'est des gens plutôt à
gauche donc des opinions politiques
diamétralement opposée au départ mais qu
on donne une de ces théories
fondamentales
ce que les élites aurait un réseau
clandestin de trafic d'enfants à des
fins sexuelles et il ya beaucoup de
femmes qui se sont sentis très
interpellé par ce danger qui planerait
supposément sur les enfants est
d'ailleurs dans le mouvement qu un oeil
le mot clic qui a été lancé save the
children sauvez les enfants et il ya
aussi un autre mot clic qui a été assez
propagée par le mouvement de
spiritualité c'est degrés awake henning
le grand réveil parce que beaucoup de
gens qui s'intéressent aux aspects un
peu plus ésotériques ont tendance à
croire que la société doit changer
fondamentalement que doit avoir une
prise de conscience globale que notre
façon de vivre dans le monde moderne
elle doit changer du tout au tout il
note aussi qu' on parle beaucoup donc
d'influenceurs dans le domaine la
croissance personnelle l'alimentation du
yoga donc des gens qui ont déjà beaucoup
d'abonnés beaucoup de gens qui les
suivent et ce sont des gens qui avec les
années on réussit à établir un lien de
confiance avec leurs abonnés parce que
parce qu'ils parlent d'eux mêmes ils
parlent de leur quotidien ils partagent
leur vie et donc ce lien de confiance le
fait que leurs abonnés sont plus enclins
à croire ces influenceurs là qu'à croire
par exemple un scientifique ou un
médecin ou un politicien et donc ça leur
donne une portée par fois plus grande
que celle qui vient des autorités en
santé publique c'est une minorité mais
une minorité qui a quand même une
certaine portée et qui réussit à
rejoindre beaucoup de gens et à les
attirer vers l'écurie du complot merci
beaucoup bougera merci à toi actuelle